ariana grande drops the teaser trailer
for thank you next and it's giving us
all those Mean Girls feels it's so
French
and on Tuesday the singer posted a first
look at her upcoming music video and it
plays off the hit 2004 flick even
addressing some of those rumors about
her one time on Twitter I heard ariana
was pregnant so I got pregnant so we
could be pregnant at the same time turns
out it was just a rumor so we all know
Ariana has clearly had a hit she's been
at the number one on Billboard charts I
mean this is truly a bob and I feel like
this is kind of like t-swift where she
did reputation and addressed everything
I mean how do you feel I think you're
right and I didn't even think about that
parallel but I loved it so true she even
jokes about her failed engagement to
Pete Davidson ariana broke off an
engagement so I found a guy to propose
to me and I broke off an engagement so I
think it's interesting that she got mad
at Pete after his SNL promo just a few
weeks ago when he joked about their
engagement do you think she's kind of
being a hypocrite
oh gosh I feel like this is the best way
for her to address it she's an artist
they both did I didn't love how Pete
handled it I really loved how are you
honest handled it so call me bias I'm
sorry all right but we want to know what
do you guys think of Ariana turning her
heartbreak into a hit I think it's a hit
and I think it's amazing that she's
doing it this way ariana did not miss a
beat with these cameos though she has
her impersonator Gabby DiMartino Troye
Sivan Colleen ballinger
she's from Miranda sings I really love
her without the red lips oh this is
really cool to see I didn't even
recognize her honestly but she also had
some original cast members from Mean
Girls Jonathan Bennett and the girl who
let Regina George punch her in the face
it was my favorite part of the video
okay of course Ariana has been teasing
videos all over social media the past
couple of weeks it's just been a flood
and I feel like we might get some
references from some of our favorite
flicks like bring it on Legally Blonde
13 going on 30 I just can't wait I'm
living for this I really truly am of
course the internet had a lot to say
lots of shade towards Gaby who was
included in the music video after fans
initially dragged her
we know the history of Ariana throwing a
little bit of subtle shade at the
impersonator in the past but I'm happy
to see that they you know seem to be on
good terms and she's in the music video
I like that - it's like a nice peace
offering people are also kind of
laughing at the timing of Miley Cyrus
announcing her big comeback yeah and
it's kind of being overshadowed by this
hilarious music video trailer and yeah I
agree I mean ariana is just topping the
charts
people are also making funny memes about
math equations thank you next you know
where she's adding up all her ex we get
it we get it it's really good but which
movie themed teaser do you predict she
will drop next I have a feeling that
she's gonna drop it just in time for
Christmas perfect for a Mean Girls
Jingle Bell Rock rendition I would
literally live for that and I'm kind of
hoping we see a little Lindsay Lohan no
yeah but we wanted a which of her famous
friends you think Ariana should enlist
in the full music video yep let's talk
all across social I met Kourtney
underscore tezo no and I met Holly
underscore Steven until next time we've
got you cover for your pop culture fixed
you
[Music]